when you send a meeting invitation
through tungl me each of your invitees
receives an
email they can see the information that
you've provided and a link to submit
their
availability first they're asked to
highlight the times when they are
available and they're alerted to the
time zone it's important to note that if
your invitees are in a different time
zone they'll see the times you've
proposed in their own time
zone you'll note that your invitees only
see the times you proposed they don't
see any of your meeting
details If This Were a one-on-one
meeting your one invitee would simply
pick the time that works for them and
book the meeting because we have
multiple invitees and want to find a
common time they're asked to select all
the times that work for
them once they're happy with their
selection they click submit my
availability have the option to add a
message and they
submit if they're not a tungl member
they don't have to register once they've
submitted their times they're
done